trois vignerons 3 philosophie dans son
vignoble de corpeau josiane taillardas
est en agriculture conventionnelle
raisonnée ici les produits
phytosanitaires de synthèse sont
utilisés mais avec parcimonie ouf
attention quand même à ne pas s' surdosé
ne pas surconsommer aussi des produits
ce que ça ne sert à rien non plus
l'enjeu ici depuis dix ans réussir à
produire 60 hectolitres à l'hectare
notre récolte est vendue tous les ans à
des négociants et où
en passant par l'agriculture mco
nationale raisonnée on procure la
récolte avec le rendement souhaité elle
envisage de passer en bio un jour mais
craint de réduire un peu sa production
le domaine etienne sauzée à pully ni
arbore déjà le label mais la philosophie
de son vignerons c'est surtout la
biodynamie c'est essayer de sentir les
choses dans un sol vivant et avec des
astros tour qui vont influer aussi sur
le comportement du végétal des plaines
une par exemple on va un peu plus de
lumière nocturne bon peut-être une
pression mildiou oïdium un peu plus un
peu plus forte de ces nuits là donc
c'est des petites choses comme ça qu'on
a précisé laurent martelé à blagny va
encore plus loin pour protéger
l'environnement son obsession réduire
son bilan carbone
les deux tiers des ressources dont j'ai
besoin elles sont à portée de main
pourquoi aller acheter un piquet en
hongrie alors que de l'acacia on en a
ici du douglas on en a dans le morvan
etc etc donc l'idée c'est dans un
premier temps d'acquérir de la forêt de
replanter des essences qui soit adaptée
au problème du réchauffement climatique
et puis d'exploiter cette ressource pour
la mettre à disposition de sa ville une
idée appliqué jusque dans sa cuverie ou
ses fûts sont fabriqués à partir du bois
de ces forêts trois méthodes donc pour
travailler la vigne trois méthodes pour
retrouver dans le vin les essences du
terroir bourguignon